katia bonjour le cortège a quitté la
place de la république qu'en est-il de
l'ambiance sur place
est ce que les manifestants ont répondu
présent
[Musique]
oui absolument ils sont plusieurs
milliers à la la question se pose est en
effet de l'affluence en ces temps de co
vide juste à la rentrée eh bien ils sont
là donc à répondre à l'appel des
syndicats fsu solidaires et la cgt sont
rejoints par des syndicats d'étudiants
des syndicats de l'enseignement des
gilet jaune des sans papiers donc des
personnes qui portent un certain nombre
de revendications que vous avez cité
notamment la hausse des salaires l'arrêt
de licenciement dans un contexte
économique est très tendue avec de
nouveaux plans de licenciements on sait
bien bfmtv nokia est maintenant encore à
nouveau à béthune
et bien voilà c'est aujourd'hui une
satisfaction pour les syndicats et pour
parler des revendications portées par
les travailleurs et les salariés du
secteur privé
je suis actuellement avec mathieu
logothetis qui est co secrétaire du snes
créteil et donc il va nous parler des
revendications portées par le milieu de
l'enseignement là qu'en est-il monsieur
logothetis des revendications
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est là parce que
on est dans une situation qui est encore
pire que celle d'avant on a des élèves
qui ont continué à augmenter dans
l'académie la coved qui s'est rajouté là
dessus et on a obtenu absolument aucun
moyen supplémentaire pour faire
fonctionner le système éducatif
donc aujourd'hui pas de surveillants
plus pas personnel d'entretien pour
faire offert nettoyage les classes sont
qu'à 35 et avec là dessus les masques
les gars contacter les collègues qui
sont régulièrement sortie pourrait
tester ce qui fait qu'on est dans une
grosse situation de tension et il ya une
yang ho une grosse volonté des collègues
devant la situation s'améliorer quand on
entend le ministre nous dire que la
rentrée est normal pour nous c'est
absolument pas acceptable
justement jean michel blanquer air qui
prétend cette rentrée normale mais vous
de votre côté non seulement dit qu'elle
n'est pas normal parce que il ya des
problèmes de personnel vue qui a de
nombreux manques à cause de la maladie
mais de nous c'est vos revendications
salariales ne sont toujours pas elle est
pas normal parce que en fait elle est
normal pour lui parce que rien n'a
changé par rapport à vent il continue à
supprimer les moyens et à désorganiser
le système éducatif avec les réformes
comme la réforme du lycée est
effectivement alors qu'on est en
situation très difficile
aucune augmentation de sauvegarde est
prévue sans contrepartie on nous annonce
des refontes du métier qui vont dégrader
nos conditions de travail mais on n'a
pas de perspective d'amélioration de
notre situation actuellement jusqu'à les
enseignants et les syndicats
d'enseignants pour se
mobiliser là dans les prochains mois ce
que vous savez déjà si des actions ce
n'est pas là c'est vrai qu'à situation
est difficile parce que la peau vite
fait que les collègues sont viennent de
reprendre ils sont assez pour l'instant
dans la tente
laissez une première mobilisation et on
espère effectivement rebondir dans les
prochaines semaines parce que on attend
des réponses fortes de la part du
ministre est pour l'instant y'a rien à
part le c'est normal et c'est pas
accepté je remercie monsieur logothetis
donc une mobilisation forte à parce que
là elle tout le monde s'interrogeait sur
la venue des manifestants et bien ils
sont bien au rendez vous ici à paris
boulevard voltaire et nous vous
tiendrons au courant au fil de la
manifestation la technique depuis le
cortège parisien merci pour cette
précision